[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from best pizza in Williamsburg where
I'm joined by Frank Pannell oh no I'm
from the pizza show on Vice Landing is
one of New York City's biggest pizza
devotees involved we're in Brooklyn New
York the motherland for the classic no
Phil slice in America today we're
exploring the obscene the viral headline
making pizzas that you've seen pop up
all over your Instagram feed and today
we're going to figure out how far is too
far I'm sort of a pizza purist so I sort
of like grew up going to these p3s
dollars it was just a square or round
slice that was your option and now I
didn't great a moment where there is no
crossing the line so this first one is
the taco taco taco pizza from Tony
boloney's this is insane this is this is
Alison I think all my guys would quit if
I asked them to make this visa sixteen
tacos on homemade tortillas topped with
mexican cheese fresh guacamole wildly
I've ever seen a piece of this crazy
before in my life
are you ready to dive in do it man not
bad I feel like if I were high in my
apartment I might make this and so this
is like Munchie food really likes to
enjoy the fact that he said that their
homemade handmade tortillas at the place
to me just gives it like another level
of like damn this pizza box fully
stocked with this pizza weighs as much
as a Range Rover tire every delivery guy
at Tony boloney's just has trapped like
Brock Lesnar what's your verdict I'm the
taco taco taco pizza from Tony boloney's
I give the Tony boloney's pizza thumbs
up I think that it's like clear that
they put a lot of effort into it I give
it a thumbs up too because you can take
it apart you can have it however you
want
you want to eat a couple tacos in the
slice of pizza it's actually not a bad
meal group next up we have the pizza box
pizzas from Vinny's pizzeria in
Williamsburg Brooklyn Wow so the pizza
comes in a pizza box made out of pizza
I'm not going to lie I've seen this one
on Instagram on the internet whatever I
wasn't sure if it was a joke or if it
was a real thing or not
but this is not a joke this is real I
think I need to just kind of like break
off yeah we got to get into this I gotta
I want to see so like it looks like
there's like a Sicilian Pete's
underneath then they got like a small
piece over here and then they just did
like this is like a pizza Bianca Moore
and they just kind of do like a little
fold over you're on and saying on top
this big thing like it needs to be
something like this needs to be like
breakaway breadstick or like something
like everything that are like perforated
lining here is something we could tear
them apart something this is too
high-maintenance for me I love the idea
of it you know what I mean I think it's
a cool idea
I just think execution-wise and I need
to work on a little I'm hanging yeah
hanging I want to see what they are
going to revisit Vinny's in two three
years see how this is a wall up next we
have love at first sight some as a
craven sandwich shop and eatery in
Queens New York and this has a little
bit of everything
mac and cheese buffalo chicken Cool
Ranch Doritos Wow all together it seems
a little bit too mushy there's no way to
figure that out is only one way to deny
it that's true all right
that's impressive right there you know
that the peak is kind of standing up to
all those ingredients on yeah you would
think that the flop factor on this would
be a lot more severe
I don't know you know what I think is
throwing me off a little bit I think
it's the Doritos you know that Dorito
does not complement a pizza the readings
on this goal it would yeah yeah the real
dose on its own is a cracker you can't
not even it you know but yeah on the
visa I don't know why it's not really
doing it for me
seems more like you just kind of get a
reaction out of someone rather than like
make a good pizza I think we're probably
in the same on this one sorry guys sorry
[Music]
up next the famous super slice from
pizza barn in Yonkers you each have our
own pizza on this one because it's just
one flight it's just one slice so if we
turn this robot on this right here pure
Instagram bait yeah pounds of dough in
every slice this is who though like the
back of it is really cooked you know
what I mean it it's cooked like a really
nice slice obviously it's gonna flop
hard oh look Wow not bad actually the
flop is and I thought now these guys did
a good job you know um the challenge to
making this pizza it hasn't a pizza man
with good hands
oh yo guys I might need some help with
this one whoa it still tastes like it
could be a normal white this is cool
bite for bite you're getting that same
experience so for me this is the thumbs
up yeah I give this one a thumbs up as
well
[Music]
this is the 24 karat gold Pizza from
industry kitchen in Manhattan this pizza
right here cost $2,000
holy [ __ ] so you do the math on math
that's two hundred and fifty dollars a
slice about $50 per bite squid ink pizza
dough okay
white Stilton cheese from England caviar
from the Caspian Sea so this is real
caviar truffles from France okay
24 karat gold leaf foie gras I'm just
all Ghana sauce Wow individually they
all took special ingredients but I feel
like all together on a pizza like this
they lose them at a 2,000 dollar price
point though you gotta put it down gotta
put some sound all right Frank
we've gone through some of the craziest
weirdest pizzas on the market I need you
the pizza guy to crown a king I think
Tony baloney gets the crown I give those
guys tops I think they got their little
niche in the market for the flat he
pieces a little bit off the beaten path
but you know it's delivered into I like
people that do that I like people have
crazy ideas that I'm surface-level but
snobs are all going to turn their nose
up at it but then when you kind of dig
into it a little bit you see that the
integrity of whatever they create it
still stands up is this safe to eat that
much gold please I guess we'll find out
I guess we'll find out cos we're not
wasting this one yeah yeah last time I
had this much gold leaf was like a
bottle of Goldschlager
[Music]